cognitive bias is the other thing that I
wanted to touch on because
I was sort of scraping through this and
it's a notion that I've come across many
times
um when it comes to beliefs and your
belief system and what
uh I mean how can I put this so I had
this business coach right
it was like 10 12 years ago you know
we've done several
several Retreats with this guy it's
[__] brilliant and you know he was
talking about your beliefs
your decisions and your results
and it kind of stems up that way you
know it's like kind of like your gut
your heart your brain whatever
um you know you hold beliefs true like I
don't know I believe that places in a
Caribbean are beautiful the beaches are
amazing weather is you know fantastic
food if you're in the right place is
great don't go to Cuba
um you get the idea right but but I mean
like you hold these beliefs and then
it's like okay well it's cold out it's
winter I don't like Canada in the winter
time I need a break from this [__] I
want to go somewhere War so now I start
making decisions okay well where do I
want to go I know this area I know this
area I know this Resort I have a friend
down there he's got an Airbnb maybe I'll
book his place sort of thing right and
then you go and then you have the
results the results are you know the
experience that you would have out of
the beliefs that you hold true and the
decisions that you make and where you go
and you know this experiences and the
stories and the photographs and the you
know the memories that you make from all
that it's the same thing with anything
else it's the same thing with
relationships you know it's the same
thing with money it's the same thing
with entrepreneurship it's the same
thing with your job it's always belief
choices results okay nobody tells you
what their beliefs are but you can
always tell what their beliefs are by
looking at the results if they have [__]
results all I have to do like I play
this game with my kid and I've said this
you know many times right whenever at
the grocery store and I see somebody
that is visually unhealthy okay you
could you put it on whatever side of the
spectrum you want but visually you can
tell they're in a sick inflamed
overweight body and you take a look at
what's on the conveyor belt that they're
about to check out on and then I take a
look at what's in my buggy because I'm
always up next right and what we look
like and I tell my kid I go you know I
want you to take a look at that and
what's on the conveyor belt and you tell
me what the difference is between those
two things and what's in our buggy and
what we look like right
these are the sort of things you know
that I'm talking about
beliefs choices results I walk through
the same grocery store
that he or she did with the buggy down
the same aisles and I put different
things in mind that they did
the frozen microwave dinners they got
the [__] candies they got the
packages and packages of chips the pops
the sugary drinks all that [__] right
I got produce I got meat
boom right I got all the good [__] right
there's a reason why you get the results
that you get there's a reason why you're
broke there's a reason why you have [__]
friends there's a reason why you have
crappy relationships there's a reason
why uh your girlfriend your wife your
gal whoever is you're dating is
disagreeable bossy fat you know whatever
like whatever it is that's you know on
your case that's bothering you it's
because you believe that certain things
are possible no it's okay it's tolerable
you know I need to I need to accept
those things it's totally totally fine
fine have fun with your results have fun
with your [__] results
you want to make those choices have fun
with those [__] results
let's go back to this cognitive bias
I think over here
um systematic so definition is a
systematic error in thinking that occurs
when people are processing and
interpreting information in the world
around them and affects decisions and
judgments that they make Okay blah blah
blah it's going to go on so
this is one of these
breakdowns that they're that they're
trying to dumb down to like a grade 8
level written by uh
a medically reviewed person with a bunch
of little letters after the name so
let's you know say the degrees up there
uh signs of cognitive bias everyone
exhibits exhibits a cognitive bias uh it
might be easier to spot in others but
it's important to know that it is
something that also affects your
thinking some some signs you might be
influenced by some type of cognitive
bias include okay so these are these are
some of the signs only paying attention
to news stories that confirm your
opinion so very true you know it doesn't
matter where you are in the political
Spectrum whether you're conservative
whether you're liberal whether you're a
Libertarian whether you're a Democrat
you know Republican every country's got
their own name for it it's just another
shade of [__] okay
um you're you're going to pay attention
to those news stories that say
go get the beer bug jab lock yourself
down
money is bad it is a root of all evil
dye your hair purple you know eat shitty
food protest for dumb things you know
you get the idea
they you know it's like a collectivism
blaming outside factors when things
don't go your way
we talked about mgtow which sort of you
know moves into like a black pill
movement which is a very nihilistic
negative sort of view and this is one of
the things that a lot of you know the
guys that that sort of you know throwing
the towel and pack it and they're just
like things aren't going my way outside
factors uh women are impossible
um
I'm not good looking enough my Skin's
the wrong color I'm not tall enough I
don't have enough hair or whatever blah
blah you know sort of [__] so you
start blaming outside factors and you're
not and you're not looking within
yourself cognitive biases right
attributing other people's success to
luck but taking personal credit for your
own accomplishments
that's a good point assuming that
everyone else shares your opinions or
beliefs and the last one on this list is
learning a little about a topic and then
assuming you know all the original about
it
I'll tell you guys right now I I don't
know [__] about [__] and I'm a lot older
um than I was when I started thinking
that I knew [__] about [__]
the deeper I go down the rabbit hole
and see things for like they goosed me
when it came to the Beer bug [__] right
the whole scandemic thing there was a
good month maybe month and a half I was
like
Mom Dad don't go shopping I'll get your
groceries and drop them off everything
you know like we'll figure this out so
like there was a time where they had me
for a month maybe month and a half maybe
a month let's say and then I started
looking at [__] and it's like you know
you start to examine you're like okay
there's a lot more to know here there's
a lot more to figure out right
um weird [__] goes on out there all the
time like
um you know I saw this earlier today
they created a vaccine like in months
you know less less than a year I don't
know what the timetable was let's call
it like six to nine months you know it
seemed like they created a vaccine very
very quickly authorized it put it in the
public but they but they can't solve
cancer right like that's not solvable
you [__] vaccina stop a pandemic you
can do that like that lickety-split
right so you start asking questions
about these things when you examine
a lot of these guys that get unplugged
and they see
things for the way they are like they
hear a sound bite like she's not yours
it's just your turn that just summarizes
that women aren't very good at being
monogamous to the first guy that they're
intimate with
that's reality
are all women like that no absolutely
not but that's in their DNA that's in
their nature there's a lot of factors
that vary around that does she have
options is she good looking enough to
move is the guy a complete loser does he
Chase Excellence there's a lot of
factors that go around that right
so you just can't make you know one call
one job like uh
assumption based on a little bit of
information I still learn more every
single day guys like I'm always reading
I'm watching videos I'm I'm
consuming books I mean I'm usually doing
about two books a month I used to do
book reviews funny thing was is some
people would watch them most people
wouldn't I'm like why am I talking about
if people aren't going to pay attention
to it [__] it I'll just read the books
and you know I'll share information as
it's relevant to topics that I'm talking
about
anyway types of cognitive biases
anchoring intentional there's a lot of
different types that they break down
here which is a dozen which is a [__]
lot I'm going to skip that causes of
cognitive bias if you had to think about
every possible option when making a
decision would take a lot of time to
make even the simplest choice because of
the sheer complexity of the world around
you and the amount of information the
environment it is necessary sometimes
Reliance and mental shortcuts that allow
you to act quickly fair enough I mean
you know fight or flight you know the
old lizard brain that you know dominates
you know oh [__] it's going to kill me I
better run away from it
cognitive biases can be caused by a
number of different things but it these
but it's these mental shortcuts known as
heuristics that often play a major
contributed role uh it's kind of
accurate they can be surprisingly active
but also lead to errors in thinking
other factors that contribute to these
biases or emotions individual
motivations limits to the mind's ability
to process information and social
pressures you know one of the things
that um I learned
what was it sapiens I think it was
sapiens
today's uh
hot drink is a mix of
Coconut Thai
chicken broth and beef broth really good
UPS my protein intake it's about 15
grams in that and that glass it tastes
really good uh anyway back to social
pressures and stuff like that
um Noah Yuval Harari wrote the book
sapiens don't like them as a person he's
a [__] he works very closely with
um
what's his name Klaus Schwab
um but I think a lot of the observations
that he published and they seem to be
well received
um is that the reason why humans exist
on such a large scale today around the
world is because of
um gossip is what it boils down to
um they all like we all agree on a lot
of commonalities like for example I
don't have my wallet here
um but you know let's say I had like a
20 bill in my hand like a USD 20
Greenback boom
if I were to show this to just about any
anyone anywhere on the planet they would
all agree that is worth twenty dollars
there's probably a handful of people
maybe some Amazon tribe in the middle of
the Jungle that has no need for money
they don't use monetary paper or
anything like that they've probably
never seen it they might wipe their ass
with it okay but the vast majority of
society would all agree that's worth 20
bucks that twenty dollars you can take
to any store pretty much anywhere in the
world and it would be exchange for goods
or services and equivalent value to 20
dollars
these these social pressures
are everywhere that's why everybody
still agrees that a 20 that you know the
USD is still the dominant currency which
we're going to see change right like
dominant currencies in the past have
moved from
uh commodity Goods straw hay milk steel
aluminum gold silver paper money Bitcoin
there's a lot less adoption on
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin than there
is with USD even though the USD is
basically [__] and will go away one day
I can guarantee that maybe my lifetime
maybe not but at some point it's going
to be [__]
social pressures push people to believe
these things and they go and Chase more
of it but they won't do things like
exchange a USD for same equivalent value
of Bitcoin is oh it's too volatile I
don't understand how it works doesn't
make any sense educate yourself look at
things right social pressures can be
very powerful
extremely powerful gossip is extremely
powerful I mean you know what 78 I think
of the uh global population
fell for the scandemic and took the
experimental uh jab because they said
that you know it was going to solve the
problem some people were coerced
basically under duress if you don't do
it you know we're going to fire you
um but the vast majority of the world
fell for it right it was only a small
portion of the the people that actually
asked questions and said uh hold on a
second let me think about that one
really you guys made this [__]
solution in six to eight months why
don't we have a solution for cancer
you can move that fast anyway
uh tips for overcoming bias
being aware of the bias consider how the
bias might influence your thinking and
one study research provided uh feedback
information that help participants
understand these biases and how they
influence decisions the results of the
study indicate this type of training
could effectively reduce you know what I
found interesting once I came across a
study
um they did it in I think it was in a
dental office in a waiting room and
everybody in the dental office in the
waiting room uh was essentially paid
actors and you know coffee table
magazines TV on the wall running the
news channel reception desk gal behind
the desk file folders on the wall like
an actual
dental studio and there was one person
there who didn't know what was going on
who was you know basically scheduling in
for a dental appointment and thought
they were going to see a dentist and
what they did was they had this beep
very loud beep that would go off I think
it was on
time schedule let's say it was like
every three to five minutes let's say
it's every three minutes it would go
beep and then everybody would stop
looking at their phone reading their
magazine watching the TV and instead of
sitting there they would stand up and
wait
10 seconds and then they would sit down
this new
um
you know individual that was that was
placed in the room to see what they
would do sat there and watched him do it
once
them do it a second time
and then in the third time she got up
and sat down with them
fourth time got up and sat down with
them it doesn't take human beings long
to follow you know what the rest of the
sheep do
okay we're herd animals
we are
that's how we've populated the world
that's how we've accomplished so much
that's how we create cities that's how
we create Road works and sewage systems
and all this [__]
that's what we are right so having some
awareness around the bias makes sense
the problem though is that you know when
you talk about like
comforting lies versus the uncomfortable
truth
just be yourself be a nice guy you know
all that [__]
and then you start seeing things like
huh well I was a nice guy I was a
shoulder that she cried on
but she went off and [__] Mr exciting
the bad boy with the tattoos on the
motorcycle right like if you've watched
enough of my stuff or if you follow me
on social media like one of the things
that I pop on social media uh often even
mostly on Twitter is I get these like
trending stories and it's like there's
always a guy you know once every couple
weeks he's like I don't understand I'm
you know I was such a nice guy and you
know I was a shoulder further crying
when her boyfriend was treating her like
[__] and we were out for a date and then
she got a text message from him and she
just left she made an excuse and she
left and she went and banged them and I
don't understand why that is because I'm
a really nice guy and I you know I think
that I deserve you know a great gal I'm
a I'm a swell dude I'm just like
well keep believing the comforting lies
in I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're newer to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out